[Music]
hey fella why are you just standing
there in that featureless boy shouldn't
you be Christmas shopping yeah I've only
got like a dollar then you can afford
the big spender magic pen sweet pen but
what is it - the big spender magic pen
lets you add your name to already sealed
greeting cards making it seem like the
gift is also from you
Wow I'm gonna use this for everything
sure use it for Christmas Wow a new car
you deserve it dad it was nothing from
Kyle and Scott thanks boys how did you
do this birthdays these are gorgeous
from your loving husband and Scott let's
have a three-way with Scott okay
[Applause]
whatever use it for weddings hey I don't
know who this guy with the giant pen is
but every single present was from him
good dog you're refusing the magic yeah
and I gots even more ideas
and the Oscar for Best Actress in the
lead role goes to Scott yeah I'm the
best actress to you sticking morons step
away from the Declaration of
Independence sir you just can't tell me
what to do I'm one of the original
founding fathers see yes sir
is there anyone we should bomb sir hmm
yeah bomb everybody don't buy this pen
humanity wasn't meant to wield its power
to buy this pen call that he didn't have
room on the screen for the phone number
so Google it well I guess I could have
said it but it's too late
right